the death toll in Iran's protest
movement has increased after Iranian
Security Forces opened fire on
anti-government protesters
[Music]
three demonstrators have been reported
dead at this protest in the western town
of mahabad on Thursday protesters
returning from the funeral of a man
killed during the unrest surrounded
government buildings and hurled Stones
rights groups say that hundreds of
people have been killed in recent weeks
amid an increasingly brutal Crackdown
let's bring in Tariq Sadiq a conflict
researcher at the University of Marburg
in Germany who specializes in the topic
of Iran welcome to the program and thank
you so much for joining us how popular
are the demands of the protest movement
Among The Wider population
so this is slightly difficult to assess
because we don't have very reliable
numbers when it comes to polling in Iran
or also crowd sizes but we do know that
a lot of the issues that are being
targeted that are being addressed here
have been increasingly popular over the
recent years and they address very
different segments of society so when it
comes to rejecting their job loss
there's a topic that's been getting very
popular as particularly in recent years
but also speaking about social issues
which have been an increasing intention
and so on and so forth I think overall
the range of topics being covered by
protesters are actually quite popular
based on what we know the protests have
been deadly the government as we we saw
there in those images
cracking down
is it fair to say that there is no hope
for reform
I would never go as pessimistic as that
but
um there have been plenty of
opportunities for reforms for the
government which it didn't take up
whether this was 2009 or 2017 or 2019 so
I would be very skeptical on whether
there is political will to begin with
but also the capacity to enact reforms
because to be fair like uh to be honest
like from the perspective of the
government which of those grievances
that are being addressed should be
addressed first if you don't enact
reforms over a decades it's very
difficult to address all of them at once
in a moment of Crisis so in that sense I
would be very skeptical about the
opportunity of reforms given that how
big a threat to the regime do the
protesters uh pose right now would you
say because the movement does indeed
appear to be gaining Steam and the
momentum doesn't seem to be dying down
anytime soon
it's probably the biggest challenge to
um the Islamic Republic since its
Inception
um we've now seen almost one and a half
months of mobilization on a very high
level and it doesn't seem to be going
down so in that sense it's not only one
of the most radical protests that we've
seen calling for the abolishment of the
Islamic Republic but also one of the
longest lasting protest movements that
we've seen six weeks of mobilization is
a formidable achievement and it does it
seems like this is going on so there's a
dedication of protesters to keep this
moving for a significantly a longer
period of time in that sense I think
it's a very big challenge to the
government itself what sort of
trajectory do you anticipate the the
movement might follow I mean how do you
see this most recent wave of protests
ending
suppose trajectories that are possible
um in particular we discussed reforms I
would never rule it out entirely even
though I think it's very unlikely um
there's also the option that protesters
uh basically enforce defections from the
state side which could all then see the
system itself crumbling we could also
see protesters outlasting the government
basically exhausting security forces
that would lead to a revolution in
itself however and this should not be
underestimated the regime still has a
significant capacity for violence and
repression so it is also possible that
there will be an escalation even of the
already high level of violence that
we've seen around right now and
repression against the protest movements
however looking at the trajectory of the
last five years whether this is the 2017
movement 2019 movement protest movements
last year and now this year I don't and
see how violence alone can end this
cycle of contention I would imagine that
even if repression becomes the main
course of action
movements like this will return maybe
next year maybe two years from now so
this is an ongoing situation that I
don't think is going to see a very quick
resolution anytime soon
Tire exotic conflict researcher at the
University of Marburg thank you so much
for joining us to share your Insight on
the situation right now in Iran
thank you